hey guys listen I wanted to create a
video on the kale shakes some people
don't want to do the berries because
it's a little too high in carb so we're
gonna make a kale shake with no extra
berries okay I'll show you how we do it
so number one it's pretty disgusting
alright the color is green well good
thing I have my spare in the right here
we're going to use that nice and new so
we'll get this thing out of there
alright put this over here okay
so what we're gonna do the first thing
we're gonna do is we're gonna blend the
kale okay so let's do that so I use the
organic kale from Trader Joe's it's all
clean its organic it's pretty cool it's
gonna happen it's gonna blend up and
kind of foam up and we don't want that
how much I use now we're gonna fill it
up to here with water okay so we filled
it up with water and now we're gonna
blend it this is really complex isn't it
it's really hard to do this okay so
we're gonna blend this about four
minutes okay so that was four minutes
okay there's nothing worse than blending
a kale shake in a weak blender because
you're gonna get chunks of fibre it's
gonna be terrible so it's a really good
blender it's called Xtreme and it works
pretty good okay so the reason I blended
the kale first is because if you add in
some of the other things that I'm gonna
show you it makes it foam up too high
but if you drank this like this it would
be pretty disgusting right so we what we
want to do first thing I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna add actually I could just
probably take off the top here okay and
I'm gonna add the lemon juice organic
lemon juice okay just like a teaspoon or
two or three this prevents the kidney
stones and calcium deposits alright so
we're going to blend it a little bit
there mix it up
don't need to do much other than that
now to sweeten this thing what we want
to do I add the raw wheatgrass juice
powder lemon flavor this is a little bit
of stevia so we have the benefit of the
sweetness without the carb and some
serious nutrition so I'll put one scoop
in there and one teaspoon is equivalent
to an entire tray about 12 inches by 24
inches of wheatgrass it's like a lot of
wheatgrass juice powder and then what
I'll do is I'll put a teaspoon of the
electrolyte powder again a little stevia
in here a little flavoring of raspberry
lemon and then we get the benefit of
trace minerals and a whole bunch of
other minerals and more potassium one
teaspoon of each so we keep the carb
down really low I'll blend that in for a
second not too much because if you
overdo it it'll just foam and come out
and the whole thing okay now if you're
going to consume this as a meal and you
want to add coconut oil you can do that
at this point as well so I'm going to go
ahead and do that I'm gonna put a
teaspoon of coconut oil in here and you
could add more if you want but this
really gives you some seriously good fat
and the type of coconut oil that I love
this is a 100% organic virgin
cold-pressed unrefined and then I will
blend this a little bit
now out of the carbohydrates in the kale
not much approaching a little protein in
fat this is a severely low glycemic
drink okay because fat does not trigger
insulin too much but the fact that
you're consuming this will stimulate
insulin just a little tiny bit if you're
in a two meal per day schedule and you
eat consume a meal and you drink all
this in one sitting that's a lot so you
can either do this during your eating
window you can do it in the morning
maybe when you wake up but what I do is
I drink some of it with a meal and then
I'll wait like an hour and I'll drink
the rest okay so again this is a very
low carb thing and I use these mason
jars so this makes about two two of
these so I have this is my entire salad
for the entire day so I'll drink both of
these for one day so I'll do one wait an
hour and do the other again it it
doesn't really matter exactly when you
consume it it's just a matter of how
much you can consume or drink during
your meal because you might be so
stuffed and we just take a straw and
we're good to go so that's the
simplicity of how I do my cows Jake
hey guys I just recently did a survey
and I found that the number one thing
that you want is to know what to eat
okay you want examples of meals so I
created a series of recipes that you can
get which basically show you how to
combine the foods in the right portions
to do ketogenic in a minute fasting
they're totally free all you need to do
is click the link below and sign up